التمريض في بريطانيا اليوم اضرابا وصف
بالاكبر في تاريخ هيئه الصحه الوطنيه منذ
انشائها قبل النحو سبعه عقود في بريطانيا
اضرب الممرضون في انجلترا وويلز وايرلندا
الشماليه بينما قرر الاتحاد النقابي في
اسكتلندا الغاء مشاركته في الاضراب وذلك
بعد مفاوضات ناجحه مع الحكومه الاقليميه
ولقد شارك عشرات الممرضين والمبردات
العاملين في هيئه الصحه الوطنيه في
الاضراب للمطالبه بزياده رواتبهم وتحسين
ظروف في عملهم
[موسيقى]
معنى الان من لندن مراسلنا اسد الله
الصاوي اسد الله اذا
تطور مقلق جدا بلا شك للمواطنين في
بريطانيا يعني الشيء يعني بالنسبه للبريد
شيء وقطاعات اخرى ولكن قطاع الصحه تحديدا
بلا شكله تاثير كبير ويسير كثير من
المخاوف حدثنا عنها لو سمحت
[موسيقى]
الاضطرابات كما تقولين قطاع الصحه القطاع
الناقله قطاع البريد وقطاعات اخرى ولكن
هذا الاضراب بالتحديد ربما
للكثير من المرضى وذويهم هنا في همم
بريطانيا
المفاوضات مستمره منذ فتره طويله بين
الحكومه
الممرضين في هذه الاقاليم الثلاثه من همم
انجلترا
وويلندا الشماليه ولكن الحكومه تصر على
عدم التحدث مع اتحاد النقابات على اي شيء
يتعلق
بالاجور بسرعه على التحدث على امور اخرى
ولكن ليس عن همم
لا لاسباب لا تعلنها الحكم المراقبون
يقولون ان الحكومه اولا اعطت الممرضين دون
عن الجميع العام الماضي همم زياده ثلاثه
في المئه وانها لا تريد الاستجابه للضغوط
لكي لا يشجع هذا نقابات وقطاعات اخرى على
تصعيد اضراباتهم رغبه في تنازل الحكوميه
الاخر وزير الخزانه
همم قال بالامس ان همم
[موسيقى]
حاله قاسيه ولا بد من شرب همم ما معناها
شرب دواء المر من اجل التخلص من هذا
التضخم سريع وبالتالي على المواطنين جميعا
يقوم بدورهم من اجل التخلص
حتى الان لم تبدي الحكومه اي رد فعل على
هذا الاضراب الذي بدا منذ الصباح اليوم
نعلم ان هناك تاثي
را عشوائيات ولكن قطاع التمريض وتوقم
التمريض قالت منذ بدايه هذا همم الاضراب
ان القطاعات الحرجه همم قطاعات مثلا غسيل
الكلى العلاج الكيماوي او ما الى ذلك كل
هذه القطاعات همم تعمل دون توقف ودون تاثر
وديع الفرصه الان للزميل المصور ليظهر لكم
حجم الحماس لدى
تمريض في هذه المستشفى الواقعه في وسط
لندن
مستمره وهذه الخطوط خطوط همم
بريطانيا
ديسمبر ولكن هذا
الاضراب حتى الان لم يحقق اي نتائج مع
الحكومه انتظر لماذا رد فعلي الحكومه في
الساعه والايام المقبله
احد اللافتات يقول ان الممرض هو للحياه
وليس فقط لفتره الكوفيت يعني ربما في هذا
دلاله كبيره شكرا جزيلا لك اسد الله
الصاوي